yeah yeah and so it begs the question
should the courts even should the
government even be in marriage to begin
with exactly i think they should okay
why the reason why i think they should
is because the idea of let's say
marriage is not something that
like let's say for example when you look
at things like let's say faith and
religion you have a lot of people that
will talk about things like sanctity of
marriage and you know the government
shouldn't be involved however i'm of the
firm opinion that matt the concept of
marriage is not exclusive to religion in
fact i would argue in many places across
the world before religion even becomes a
thing
there is um concepts and ideas of you
know of marriage
you know if we're gonna say for example
live in a free society you know in
in you know in a world where you want
your spouse to have control over things
like if you're on your deathbed do they
turn off the life support or keep it on
you need that to be kind of recognized
and
legalized do you see what i'm saying
so for example if i've for whatever
reason inexplicably got married
and something happened to me i don't
know i got run over by by you know the
one four nine on the high street
and you know i'm almost
couldn't they just ask you couldn't they
just ask every person i don't know who
the person because think about it like
this about your relatives your mother
your father your brother that's what i'm
saying when you wanna marry someone and
form a family you don't want your is and
not to say you don't want but should
your
birth family like you know your mother
your father should they have
choice over your actual partner who
you've married and who you've created a
brand new friend you can just walk away
and take your stuff any day anyway bro
and turn your button off and take your
money so i'd rather have my mother do is
unconditionally being her son that's
unconditional that woman who hasn't got
unconditional love for you
failed to provide the requirements she'd
be leaving you anyway now you're
completely let alone giving her the
power to shut your life down but you
you're completely right but you have to
kind of think of it like this if you're
the type of person who you know who you
get married and you actually create a
family that's your family no i agree
with
you
that's kind of the only reason why i
would say
in in terms of recognizing marriage it
should be recognized in the government
in terms of stuff like let's say things
that are more traditional you can do all
the bells and whistles go to church go
to the mosque go to synagogue or you
know if you're indian maybe in a temple
do you know what i'm saying but i'm
saying i have the traditional aspects
couldn't they just have something on
your license with who who you want to be
your emergency contact or something like
if they had things like that which took
care of the whole legal side of it 100
percent why should the
because it's like your next of kin
that's what it is bro pretty much i mean
i guess but wouldn't you have to the
power of attorney when someone dies and
so forth i used to work in a bank for
five years it can easily be done without
having any sort of marriage whatsoever
it could be your best buddy that you
grew up and went
nursery primary school could be whoever
you deem correct and someone who you
know is willing to actually maybe stand
by a side fight and die for you or your
mother or father who you know was
willing to die for you unconditionally
the fact of the matter is this person
even though your family does become your
family they still shouldn't have that
authority i don't believe but i can see
why people do it if they're in a perfect
harmonic synergistic masculine feminine
relationship then yeah maybe it can work
but in general hit that prenup bro and
have your one of your family members do
it for you yeah that is true i mean
i was just gonna say but wouldn't you
want all those things in your partner
anyways so you would want one in your
partner so yeah what i was just talking
about yeah that's what you'd hopefully
have so if that was the case i see the
argument for it but to be honest how
many marriages end up in divorce anyway
well and the problem is a lot of girls
change once they get the ring
and guys will say this like oh in the
honeymoon phase she was the best
girlfriend ever
can you argue that both ways i was gonna
say a lot of men as well they will give
you right right but we don't have the
risk they do yeah you don't lose so
yeah so i mean it with us it's like we
don't we don't run the risk but they
they we we can get a check out of it but
then if it goes wrong and it's the wrong
person she can take half your [ __ ]
that's true that's why you've heard it's
cheaper to keep her it's true granted i
would probably argue if you know if kids
weren't factored into it it might be
more fair and the only reason why i was
i'm saying that is because it could
easily work the other way what do you
mean what i'm saying for example let's
say you were in a relationship where
the um wife was somehow making more
money than the husband their assets are
all shared if they were to split up she
would equally lose half of her [ __ ] not
particularly the court's favor men
i don't know generally speaking oh sorry
women i know what you mean generally
speaking you know
the courts do but i'm just kind of
saying where if it was somehow skewed on
the other end it would apply in the same
way if they were to divorce the only
time it generally doesn't is when
children are factored into it well i
don't understand why child support began
like i don't understand why child
support is there to begin with like why
are you entitled to someone's money
why do you deserve it you can get a job
i work yeah i feel like
support assumes that the father is not
going to be present and competent yeah
and that's not fair i was going to say
and there's many ways to support
children and the last way is in my
opinion is financially so yeah i agree
with you on that point i i think that
child support is a very
business like transaction like process
that supports women kind of
you know benefiting financially while
still they're not in the relationship
anymore and because the way that the
british government works there's no kind
of foundation around okay what can i
spend this on is there
a system where this can only be used on
children's swings or cl you know what i
mean
i'm just a big believer and you made
your bed lie in it
so if you're if you're worried if you're
worried he's not going to stick around
maybe you should have picked a better
guy because i don't i don't i don't find
that most women that are in these
situations had zero red flags and zero
warning signs and he just magically
switched one day you either knew he was
going to be a good father and a good
husband yeah and and
yeah
and he is and if that's the case and it
doesn't work out he will likely take
care of his kids anyway
or you're dating pookie and ray-ray
and you're when you're and you're
shocked that they're not fathers and
husbands i was going to say that this is
the problem as i said you said on the
last show the thing with women and
relationships is when the man departs or
leaves the relationship they still want
to have control and this is not control
over just the finances but control over
him his emotions if there's children
involved that is a bargaining chip and
having the financial means to control a
man's uh
rent the way he pays his bills the way
he operates in his daily life without
even having contact with him
i think
it's very very uh divisive speaking to
the mic oh
oh it's right next to my face
okay and then um
but
it's
it's designed in a way like he said that
the man does lose
a lot of women because they don't have
the man they want to control him outside
of having a relationship just say
something about this whole the man loses
yeah i understand like when you divorce
a woman you're losing fifty percent x y
and z
this might be a bit outlandish but in my
eyes
you're a man you are provider do you
understand so if you notice a part of
your risk why why are you so scared of
this risk you're gonna go off anyways
and you're gonna provide for yourself
because before you got into this
marriage you made sure that you could
provide for yourself and your partner
and your future family so for the fact
that like leaving this woman or
divorcing this woman now you're thinking
oh 50 is gone and i have to pay x y and
z this is a part of something that is
innately within you it is to provide
yeah but so for your family you're no
longer your family yeah provide for the
kids not some woman has walked out
broken up the family house and this is
where they're going and now it's talking
about give me half of your income that
income should go directly to the
children her income should go directly
to the children they can live a separate
life hopefully be amicable or
respectable but most most guys are cool
with with providing for their kids what
they don't need is the government
telling them that they have to yeah and
putting a gun to their head and sending
them to prison if they don't i agree
with that that's why i said it's more of
like within the man's character and not
the legal side but then but then it goes
back to like it's on us it's on us to
pick the guy yeah and so and so i think
a lot of times women are always bailed
out for our bad decisions
so so we can we can pick the wrong guy
right have a kid by him then the
government pays us out for being a
single mom
and we get we get better housing because
we're a single mom so bailed out for
that decision then on top of that we're
entitled to his income so we get bailed
out again instead of saying hey
pick better guys you made your bed lie
in it you need to figure it out it's not
the government's job and it's not his
job to figure it out